In this question, you're going to go to the Play Store
and find an app you don't like, and then we're going to deconstruct
why. Now, you may already have an app in mind, something you've
used and don't like. You can use that. If you do go
to the Play Store, you may have to look a bit.
Sometimes Play Store will tend to feature the higher rated apps, of
course, so you may have to dig a little deep. After you
find an app you don't like so much, you should make two
flows, in Prezi. In the first flow you will describe, or depict I should say,
one flow through the app as it currently exists. I say one flow, because complex
apps can have a complicated hierarchy of
potential flows. After you do this, you're going to
think at a high level. Now, what about
this flow is making you unhappy? And then,
you're going to fix it. Now, not every app that displeases you
is wrong because of its high level flow. You may just
not be the intended audience. But hopefully you can find one
where this is the case, and focus on it. Once you've
made your two flows, you're going to post to the forum. You
can either find the thread in the instruction that's below, or
in the discussion section off to the side. The goal of
this whole question is to get your thinking and speaking like
a designer, and making high level improvements to products.